are you ready to see your fixer-upper
that is HGTV's fixer-upper husband and
wife team chip and Joanna Gaines helping
folks buy fixer uppers and transform
them into dream homes I love these two
and by the way I'm not the only one cuz
the show is breaking ratings record
after ratings record with women so I go
home we're chip and Joanna so you can
meet the couple behind the phenomenon
hey guys thank you for ear instead of oh
oh what what you see is what you get
with the gains they are the most
down-home real people you'll ever meet
they laugh are you and he's always
kidding around I mean as you like this
out oh my goodness I tell him it's
censored what you see on TV is censored
he's ten times crazier in real life and
I get to put up with I'm the lucky lady
we take the worst house in the best
neighborhood and we turn it into our
clients Dream Home for me it's a dream
come true because at the end of the day
what we're passionate about is creating
home for families you just thought we'd
be successful but I mean did you think
it would ever be anything whenever a TV
show and never on this national like
platform based in Waco Texas their
company has remodeled well over 100
homes and Counting they're becoming an
empire they run a home goods website a
bed-and-breakfast a real estate company
and the retail store Magnolia market
gets more than 25,000 visitors a week
they invited me along on one of their
makeover jobs this couple never stops
look at these man I love these stores
you guys can't even walk around Waco
without people coming up to you and
getting bombarded by the autographs and
photographs what's what's not like just
going out to the grocery store you
forget and you wonder why it why are
people scaring me why anything like oh
okay you decide we're not used to it yet
home is this one hundred thirteen year
old farmhouse where they're raising
their four kids but they have to watch
fixer-upper at a friend's house cuz they
don't own a TV but we waste joke when we
go on vacation or we're traveling for
the show we make up for we will sit in
the hotel
and instead of exploring the amazing
city oh yeah oh my goodness look what's
on TV yeah we'll just binge watch who
needs TV when you live on your own
picture-perfect
40 acre farm here they go here they go
come on in old mouse get ready goats
chickens horses and Texas longhorn
cattle that chip herds on his ATV you
know it's almost like the American
dreams and I couldn't leave Waco without
get my hands dirty chip challenge me to
a demolition derby
three two one hey Jim look at how you're
getting it Oh first head through the
wall wins did I win no where are you
where are you okay good